hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd youtube video and in this one i'll be
showing you guys a new feature of
youtube which allows you to edit your
youtube groups so i'm going to open up
my mkbhd group here and maximize it and
you'll be able to see this group
featured on my channel and the link will
be in the description in case you
actually want to edit this but what
we're going to do or actually join this
group so what we're going to do is
actually show you uh the new feature at
the top you can see here if you are the
owner of a group you can edit the
information of the group as of about
three days ago
from the date that i'm making this video
so it's really cool uh that youtube's
finally integrated this feature i've
been waiting for it for a while people
have been asking me how can i edit the
group how can i do it i haven't really
been able to answer so now i can finally
give you that answer
so you can see at this top banner here
under the home videos and channels etc
you have a settings button for editing
your group you just expand settings and
you can change the group name you can
add some tags
and you can change the description of
the group so that's a a big thing that a
lot of people wanted to change was a
typo they had in the description well
now you can finally do that also by
default this tends to be in autos and
vehicles you want to change your group
category to something that really
represents what you do
to make it easier to find so mine will
science and technology
you can make your group public or
protected which requires your founders
approval to join meaning you'll get an
email or private and by invite only so i
have mine at public
video uploads and forum postings are
immediate for mine again i have
moderators for that and i'm constantly
adding moderators and have a group icon
which obviously i let my owner i am the
owner uh pick the group icon and i use
the uh pablo silva intro videos
thumbnail for that so once you're done
editing your youtube group just hit save
changes um it's very quick it just saves
all the changes to your group you still
as of yet can't change the background or
the theme or anything of the group
or the default view whether it's in grid
or in play version but i think it's nice
that you can at least change some of the
information about your youtube group uh
before other people you know get a hand
on it and um it's really nice to see
that so if you are a modern night in my
youtube group i just go ahead and let me
know if you can actually do this i think
it's only the owner of the group that is
able to do this uh but until then thanks
for watching this hd tutorial just a
very very quick announcement video and
again stay tuned for the mkbhd update
video where i cover a lot of topics that
have been you know mentioned and
questioned to me in the past couple of
days so anyway i hope you enjoy this new
feature where you can actually edit the
youtube group description and all that
tags and everything and uh thank you for
watching this update video guys so see
you guys in the next tutorial peace